joining us now is the former head of the
British Army general Lord done it thank
you very much for being on the show this
morning Sophie good morning I'm really
interested to know what you think the UK
government should do should we be taking
back Islamic state fighters and putting
them on trial well I think usually I
disagree with what Donald Trump says but
on this occasion I think he's right if
there are as I think it's correct to say
a large number of foreign fighters in
captivity in Syria who originate from
countries like the United Kingdom then
they are our citizens and we have a
responsibility to act responsibly
towards them and I think that means that
they've got to come back to this country
they've got to be held while they talk
to and if there is sufficient evidence
against any of them or many of them then
they've got to put through be put
through due process and imprisoned if
that is the right thing to do but I
think it's also important that we treat
them fairly and we treat them with
justice but tempered with a bit of mercy
as well because I think the the way we
treat them may well have important
significance for the way other people
view our society we don't want to see
others being radicalized and going off
overseas and in the future so I think
how we treat these people coming back
we've got to treat them fairly but
firmly I think it's important that we
get that right so in this case I think
Donald Trump is right there our
responsibility we've got to take them
back I mean this has really come into
the news recently because of the
discovery of Shamima Begum the girl who
left Bethnal Green to join Islamic state
in Syria lots of kind of members of the
public feel that she shouldn't be able
to come back but from what you're saying
it sounds like you think that actually
she's the British citizen so she should
be well you've got to turn it around and
say if she's not going to come back here
where is she going to go she can't stay
in a in a refugee camp in Syria for the
rest of her life it's not right to say
that well Americans can take her and the
other fighters and stick them in
Guantanamo if these people are British
French German citizens they're in
Britain France Germany or whatever ever
other country has to take responsibility
for their citizens
now taking responsibility it means that
we bring them back we talk to them we
investigate them and if there are
charges that can properly be laid
against them then that should be the
case and they should be put through the
judicial process and punished
accordingly
but I think it's important that we do
treat these people fairly as I say I
think how we treat them will be seen by
other minority populations in our
country and that will affect how they
behave in the future it's really
important we get this right the problem
is though it's proven very difficult to
actually put suspect as members of
Islamic state through trial and actually
put these people in prison hasn't it and
you can see why members the public might
be very worried about the threat to our
own national security if they return
home I completely agree with that I mean
I think it's a real challenge for our
authorities but it's but just because
it's a challenge doesn't mean to say we
shouldn't rise to it and try and get it
right
they've been radicalized over a period
of time they can be talked to there are
some who may will want to change their
way their lives are led and live more
conventionally there are others that
perhaps will never change their mind in
which case they are likely to be in
prison for quite some time each case has
got to be treated separately and judged
on its own merits but without repeating
myself unduly I think how we treat these
people is really important for the
effect it will have on others in the
future and on our own society and I
think the big challenge for us and we
were saying this back in 2014 2015 is to
ask ourselves why with all the
opportunities in this country what a lot
of young people want to forsake all that
and go away on fight and fight in
somewhere like Syria and Iraq I think
the challenge for our society is to make
it sufficiently attractive enough
opportunity for people through education
and jobs and living a better life
that they want to stay and make a future
in this country and not feel they've got
to go and chase some errant dream
elsewhere I'm interested to know your
thoughts on the current situation in
Syria as well because Donald Trump's
also tweeted to say we're pulling back
after a hundred percent Caliphate
victory has there been a hundred percent
victory and are you happy to see the
u.s. pulling back their troops in Syria
well I think there are several issues
there the Caliphate in 2014-15 made a
strategic error which has worked to our
advantage in that they chose to occupy
large sways of territory and in doing
that they then provided themselves set
themselves up if you like as a physical
target that could be attacked and over
the last four or five years that's
what's happened their territory has
gradually been reduced their towns and
cities have been recaptured Raqqa most
prominently fell quite some time ago and
they are reduced to a very small little
bit of territory which will probably be
overrun by Allied forces really quite
soon that doesn't end the Caliphate idea
it's an ideology it's a dream it's a
vision and it will reoccur elsewhere I'm
afraid that's just a fact of 21st
century life the fundamentalist Islamist
movement that we've been combating and
seen so sort of all over the place since
9/11 is going to pop up elsewhere we're
seeing it particularly in sub-saharan
Africa at the present moment and that is
a concern as we will probably see it
elsewhere in the Middle East so it's not
it's not a hundred percent victory we
may well complete the recapture of the
territory that they had but the ideology
the thinking the support behind it that
is going to continue and that will
become or will remain the struggle for
this generation perhaps even the next
generation as well and now it feels like
I can't get through an interview in a
minute without mentioning breakfast so
I'm interested to know your thoughts on
whether Britain's role in the world is
going to be increased or diminished
after we leave the European Union well
given we are going to leave the European
Union on the 29th of March in some shape
or form and we'll have a continuing
relationship with Europe again of some
shape or form almost by definition we
are therefore saying we want to pay a
more global role and we want to be
trading with Commonwealth countries with
if we can restore relations with China
after the aircraft carrier business we
all want to do that trade with India so
we will want to take a more global
position and I think that's a perfectly
reasonable
thing for us to do and it's not just
about trade I think it's about influence
as well and we have to work out how
we're going to exercise that influence
and I think there's an important
harmonization between our diplomatic
skills our defense capabilities and the
way that we use our development money as
well as trade I think put all those
things together and that is the way the
UK should use its influence been
officially in the world in the future as
well as improving our trading
opportunities now you've served in
Belfast in the early 1970s and in your
memoirs you wrote that this was not just
writing and civil disorder it was war so
from your wealth experience over across
the sea what would be the consequences
of a hard border between Ireland and
Northern Ireland and are you worried
that politicians are putting the peace
process at risk
well the peace process must not be put
at risk just to go back to the start of
your comment there in 1972 alone we lost
102 British soldiers killed in the
province of Northern Ireland that's a
figure that was only exceeded once of
the combined operations in Iraq and
Afghanistan in more recent times so a
tremendous amount of blood and treasure
was expended in making life in Northern
Ireland much more peaceful much better
for the inhabitants of of Northern
Ireland so whatever happens we must make
sure that we don't provide conditions
again whereby Northern Ireland can
regress to a position akin to the
troubles which went on for such such a
long time so this whole business of a
hard border there must not be a hard
border
I'm afraid I'm one of those that
believes that with imagination and
determination there are ways that can be
produced which means that we can can
continue to trade between Northern
Ireland and the Republic of Ireland
without having to go to men with
clipboards and flat caps standing at
country checkpoints frankly if you buy a
newspaper in its barcoding I can't
really see why goods and services can't
be identified traced taxed as necessary
at their points of origin and don't have
to be taxed at the point at which they
cross an international boundary
um well let's fingers crossed hope
you're right and the defense secretary
moving on made a pretty forward speech
this week shall we say he said he wants
to see increased lethality the chances
now to abandon a trip to China after he
said he wanted to send a warship into
the position Pacific Russia have dubbed
him the Minister for war rather than the
Minister for defence do you think he
needs to tone it down a bit
well Gabby Williamson is a very
enthusiastic individual and he's taken
his portfolio defense seriously yes I
think we all know he's pretty ambitious
as well and wants to use defence as a
platform to develop his own career I'm
afraid a number of politicians do that
he's also recognized I think quite
correctly that we do not spend enough on
defense in this country when Philip
Hammond was a sector State for Defence
seven eight nine years ago we were
spending about 2.4 percent of GDP on
defense and now it is just down to 2
percent so Gavin Williamson is trying to
make the case for us to spend more on
defense was he right to say we're going
to send our aircraft carrier off to the
Spratly Islands to be honest I don't
think years
I think actually it's premature the
aircraft carrier Queen Elizabeth is a
very fine looking ship but it hasn't got
its full complement of airplanes yet so
let's get the thing properly equipped
properly sorted out and then use it
responsibly just because we've got it
doesn't mean to say we use it most
defense capabilities we hold in
readiness for something that really
demands them to be used we don't just
use it or send it because we can so I
think come I think you may have actually
just over sold that one over the last
few days and if it has had the
disappointing effect the Chancellor's
trip to China largely going to be
talking about trade and that kind of
thing if that's if that's been cancelled
result then that's a bad bad diplomatic
move and then Gavin's got that one wrong
okay now while we've got you I have to
ask you and this week the Shadow
Chancellor John McDonnell said that
Churchill was a villain because of his
role in tony pandey so i'm going to put
the same question to you
winston churchill hero or villain
well I'm an unreconstructed fan of
Winston Churchill and as far as I'm
concerned he made virtually every
mistake in the book which he learned for
a lot of those experiences as he went
through his career but he was the right
man for this country in May 1940 and I
often think if Lord Halifax had become
Prime Minister I think he'd have made a
separate peace with Hitler in May 1940
and they may well have come after us the
following year I think the map of Europe
would look very different and the brexit
debate we're having would probably be
completely irrelevant okay Lord done it
thank you very much we're very beautiful
but surely looking Norfolk I'll let you
go and warm up thank you